hicieron esta mañana quiero que esa
pregunta pasa por su cabeza ahorita
porque yo siempre que el lado terminó
llegando a una reflexión imagínense que
algún día deciden hacerle esta pregunta
a algún familiar algún conocido o
simplemente una persona que se
encuentren y ellos les responden pues
hoy me desperté a las 6 de la mañana
desayuné me cambié me vestí y me fui al
trabajo a la escuela y después de eso se
dan cuenta que esa pregunta no estuvo
nada mal así que deciden hacerla el
próximo día y reciben la misma respuesta
se despertaron a las 6 de la mañana se
cambiaron desayunaron y salieron al
trabajo a la escuela es aproximadamente
al quinto día o al sexto que te das
cuenta de que esta persona está en un
ciclo
un día que empieza de una manera
continua de otra y luego acaba de esa
misma manera si solo vuelve a empezar y
es lo mismo una y otra y otra vez
y por qué es esto malo porque es malo
que vivamos en una rutina pues verán
estamos tan acostumbrados a este pequeño
ciclo
se nos olvida que hay más afuera de eso
que la vida tiene tanto que ofrecernos y
que conocemos tan poco de eso y cómo
podemos salir de él
como podemos salir de la rutina pues
primero déjenme les cuento una historia
personal una anécdota
hace aproximadamente dos años ya casi 3
yo me estaba preparando por una cosa que
se conoce como el ex papel ahora tal vez
algún ustedes estén familiarizados con
su hijo la hizo hoy pero déjenme les
explicó brevemente que es un ex profeta
la expo pp es una exposición que se
lleva a cabo el último año de primaria y
es muy importante porque es en donde se
une todo lo que has visto en toda
primaria así que todos se la toman muy
en serio también es calificación pero
esta parte
así que para uno de estos trabajos a mí
se me pidió que investigara el origen de
mi apellido así que yo fui no pensé
mucho este trabajo pero lo hice y cuando
lo hice me encontré con esto ahora les
voy a dar un rato para que lo lea
déjenme saber con hielo acabaron de ver
y ahora acaban de leer todos
pues la primera vez que yo leí esta
dirección principal fue algo parecida a
ésta
porque en el momento ni siquiera sabía
que era un rey godo solo supe que se
escuchaba importante
y aún hasta el día de hoy apenas me
enteré de qué significan
y les quiero plantear una pregunta
ustedes creen que estas personas vivían
lo mismo todos los días o en algún
momento alguien decidió hacer un cambio
salir de su rutina salir de su ciclo
salir de lo que no conoce y descubrir
nuevas cosas hasta que de un rey godo
pasó a mí ahora qué es una mejor es otra
cosa pero de que hubo un cambio y
alguien descubrió algo hubo un cambio yo
no tengo manera de verificar este
conocimiento pero yo les puedo decir que
sé que hay miembros de mi familia que
provienen de españa y ahí solito hay un
cambio muy grande así que volvamos a la
pregunta
estas personas agarraron su ciclo y
encontraron una salida una manera de
escapar
lo que viven así que ahora sí volvamos a
la pregunta cómo empezar cómo podemos
salir de nuestra rutina y de lo que
conocemos pues de qué me lo digo lo que
yo he estado haciendo porque estaba
haciendo algo
desde ese mismo año que investigue el
origen de mi apellido me di cuenta de mi
ciclo en mi rutina calle en la
realización de que estaba viviendo lo
mismo así que decidí empezar a hacer
cosas nuevas y empezar a intentar cosas
que nunca había hecho y la forma en la
que se hace
la forma en la que hice esto fue con
pequeños saltos mch
pequeños saltos
agarré mi ciclo y encontré maneras de
dar pequeños saltos y lo que quiero
decir con estas que agarren lo que hacen
todos los días y encuentren una pequeña
salida donde puedan ver cosas nuevas
en estos brincos lo más probable es que
se encuentren con cosas que les gusten o
que no les gusten y esa es la idea si se
encuentran con algo que les gusta lo más
probable es que decidan seguir avanzando
en eso y seguir y seguir y tal vez algún
día no se den cuenta y ese pequeño
brinco fue creciendo en un brinco más
grande tal vez el brinco y terminó
creando otro brinco hasta que un día ya
ni siquiera están en un círculo están en
una línea recta porque siempre están
avanzando y descubriendo
y estos brincos son la cosa más difícil
que han hecho en toda su vida así que
les recomiendo que hagan que empecemos a
decir sí
si empezamos a decir si estamos
aceptando las oportunidades que nos trae
el mundo
y créanme hay momentos en los que tienen
que decir no un gran ejemplo de esto es
cuando por fin aceptan el té de hierbas
no me recomendó que aquí diera el
discurso del coral blanco
ahí tienes que decir no
pero
y yo creo que el mejor ejemplo que tengo
de cuando tiene que decir si fue hace un
mes tal vez menos tal vez más que yo
estaba sentado con mis amigos en clase
de español y llegaron tres personas al
salón estaban para ofreciéndonos
platicar en un télex
al principio yo me iba a ir como los
demás ni siquiera iba a levantar mi mano
y decir que no iba a seguir trabajando y
no iba a hacer nada y cuando ya estaba a
punto de dejar que salieran por la
puerta me puse a pensar levante mi mano
y dije sí y ahora aquí estoy
presentándome a todos ustedes los quiero
invitar a que la próxima vez que se les
presente una oportunidad la piense y en
vez de solo decir no digan sí porque
cuando decimos si salimos de nuestra
rutina salimos en nuestro ciclo y
conocemos algo extraordinario muchas
gracias